le leem c'est à ce moment de l'explosion
les vidéoclubs tous les rapports
américain
steve reich tonnes
d'or
le lean les 16 heures où le propos zhang
comme on surnomme dans la rue c'est
enfin sirops contre la toux à la codéine
ou un autre pionnier comme hydrocodone
mélangé à une boisson gazeuse
déjà dans les années 60 des bluesmen de
houston ont versé dans leur bière
[Musique]
dans les années 90 la drogue est adoptée
par une partie de la communauté rats et
depuis quelques années elle est plus
populaire que jamais gucci mane futur
léopold certains des plus grands noms de
la scène rap en parle dans leurs
morceaux
[Musique]
bieber n'en avoir été dépendant dans un
documentaire diffusé en 2020
et on en voit partout sur les réseaux
sociaux
le ligne devenue tellement populaire que
des individus en fabrique aujourd'hui
des versions contrefaites
c'est loin d'un produit pharmaceutique
la façon dans une caisse en place un
maillage
de la formation le sud
mais dans la rue les vrais line est une
denrée rare qui se vend à prix d'or
contacté sur instagram deux revendeurs
devraient sirops contre la toux à la
codéine ont accepté de me rencontrer
leurs bouteilles proviennent directement
de pharmacie grâce à des intermédiaires
qui ont accès à des prescriptions ou de
l'étranger de pays où la loi est plus
laxistes
sur sa table pour
communiquer couzier d'allah de ce héros
un petit peu un tube du moment
pourquoi ça vaut si cher que ça c'est du
sirop contre la toux cheveux bagad la
codéine dedans
mais c'est plus cher que les meilleurs
champagnes musulmans de plaisir c'est
aussi parce que tout ça soit aussi
difficile d'accès mais aussi s'est
rendue de plus en plus cela renvoie au
dessus l'impression qu'il ya une
recrudescence ou un gain d'intérêt comme
si le pour cette drague lancement
c'est sur son mac os dur a justement vu
que c'est exclusif donc c'est une bonne
difficiles d'accès comme celle ci qui
est cher nous appelons faire l'apologie
rien en 2000 dollars en lots vers 205
ans de l'autre côté les pharmacies il ya
des restrictions c'est le bac c'est ça
ça augmente repris fait de plus en plus
tu vois qu'il faut qu'ils tombent dans
la rue de plus en plus comment savoir
des contrefaçons il a fait en sorte que
le vrai commence à coûter plus cher
j'ai rencontré un de ses producteurs de
faux sirop à la codéine et je vais
visiter ce que certains appelleraient un
laboratoire clandestin dans son garage
facile peux-tu m'expliquer ce que tu
fais s'asseoir ici en fait
on charbonneau ont fait appeler avec un
peu de volonté gardant mon enfance mais
perfection
mais nous savons
[Musique]
qu est-ce qui atteint souvent le fond
c'est la prometteuse en cours avec tout
ce qui est rare côté
je joue maintenant ce sont des sept
chiots à blaye sommeil ça goûte impulse
immense convoi dans le vaisseau s'est
pas exactement
quel thé pharmaceutiques 1 bat donc on
sera jusqu'en haut
j'trouve ça ou la codéine quelle semaine
à ces produits c'est une autre étape
normalement si ce qu'un conte ne
promettons quelqu'un c'est presque ce
pour un mal colak ce soir ce sera plus
long sinon je suis inquiète des fois on
n'a pas de poutine a au moins fait
tomber des défis mille collines
n'importe quoi qu'est-ce qu'on peut
trouver qui
en laboratoire on ne peut du chum et son
époux riat on a pour seul tropez ont
fait du bon lui
la consommation des creative de codéine
et dangereuse crise en trop grande
quantité elle peut causer des
dépressions respiratoires
surtout lorsque mélangé avec d'autres
drogues ou de l'alcool
au québec kevin denis un jeune lavallois
de 26 ans est mort d'une surdose en 2020
il a subi le même sort que dj school le
producteur de rap texan qui a popularisé
line décédé en 2000
[Musique]
la popularité du ligne ici en tout cas
par de l'eau vient de l'autre mais
non est un revenant jeunesse à chambly
c'est l'éveil en cause s'est frotté à ce
monde pendant des années avant d'opter
pour la sobriété c'est ainsi qu'on
semble que tu as eu du fun c'est une
chose que tu consommes à ce que al mal
de vie fut que sa voix 1er août et
pourra pas gérer des émotions pour avoir
en parler des programmes de demander de
l'aide on n'est pas la glace tout à fait
cela
toute sa
jeunesse quand même qu'on semble acquise
à la cocaïne mais j'ai essayé pas mal
tous des droits qu'ils estiment le
l'insee
constate aussi que le
site était en danger a dit brice
viva chile bit sera l'axé vie
sociale
c'est yann lavoix puis les
en raison de la popularité du lean la
gendarmerie royale du canada a ajouté la
codéine à son tableau de sensibilisation
aux drogues qui notamment distribué dans
les écoles secondaires et je dois dire
que j'en entends parler de plus en plus
on est dans la même famille que les
royals en trop que le fentanyl donc est
ce que c'est possible d'en prendre trop
et de faire un arrêt cardio-respiratoire
tout à fait de se retrouver dans le
comment tout à fait et que ça peut mener
jusqu'à un décès c'est des choses qui
sont arrivées tout à fait
ici on ne parle pas de médicaments
disponibles sur les tablettes une
prescription d'un médecin est nécessaire
pour acheter la plupart des sirops à la
codéine les pharmaciens peuvent aussi en
distribuer des versions beaucoup plus
faible en narcotiques à leurs clients un
jeune de 15 7 ans qui va à la pharmacie
la pie qui s'est lui-même qui veulent du
sirop à la codéine
red flag
on devrait pas avant ses produits longs
en vente libre mais comme les patients
sont orphelins les patients ont pas
accès facilement leur médecin de famille
quelquefois il faut quand même que le
pharmacien se retrouve avec des
solutions sous la main pour aider des
gens qui sont mal pris ok donc ceci
sauces et des produits qui sont ces
tribus seulement avec une prescription
oui puis on en voit de moins en moins le
lit médecins sont frileux avec les
opiacés la dernière année mais quand ils
vont en donner c'est vraiment un code de
crosse tout puis à ce moment là les
quantités sont quand même assez
restreint qui inquiète est ce qu'on
pourrait penser que le fait que les
médecins et les pharmaciens
se fait qu'ils soient de plus en plus
frileux à prescrire ou à donner ce genre
de produit la basse a poussé le marché
noir à en créer de façon contre cette
hausse relative ainsi sauf que c'est ce
qui s'est produite et aux etats unis
quand alain fontanel est devenu plus de
ces lourds l'axé contraintes devenu plus
difficile d'accès pour les patients qui
avaient pu des producteurs qui en
donnait aisément le match et la
contrefaçon s'est fait plus dans le fond
la dépendance se déplace à ce moment là
d'un produit à l'autre
bon
bah moi je peux aller croche pour
ça
la cades et non pas gamme de nokia car
mode pro mesurer grand chose ça peut
être dangereux de consommer cinq mois
sous le feuillage est avec moi me
dérange comme on dit ça permet de vendre
un produit dans aucune idée de la teneur
finalement ça c'est des jeunes qui vont
tout est bon chez pas la moitié là c'est
comme à ceux qui exposent une exacte
mais moi je vais maintenant parce que
j'ai expérimenté j'ai fait expérimenter
avant de le vendre quoi c'est pas femme
à 7,5 starace sur mes gardes on fait
avec ce qu'on a tous compris
en boîte ce temps près de wajid ajouté
c'est le temps qu'elles ont recommandé
dans le bourg trop de ton point tu vas
12 ans
et préside achète achètent sur la dalle
led sont pas nécessairement testés sont
là tous entendu qu'il s'agit d'un petit
peu de fin d'année pour éventuellement
créer une surdose s'apprête arrivé
dessus sur god on n'est pas l'abri de
tout
c'est un fauteuil qui rendent ce
on joue à la roulette russe est aussi
simple que ça on a une fausse impression
de sécurité parce qu'on a une bouteille
de sirop qui a l'air d'une vraie
bouteille sais pas d'où ça vient c'est
pas qui a fait ça s'est passé la
personne qui en fait
même si j'ai fait qu'est-ce que la mi
temps
toi tu es 100% certain que c'est vrai
lit tout certifié 100 % directement la
santé de la pharmacie vous êtes au
pouvoir gaston président le suisse ont
provoqué bon je me demanderais ce que je
me sens moins de novembre
ont nécessairement vivant se sont
répandus là parce que les jeunes
certaines demandes
et spécialise la santé les corps
policiers auront beau vouloir contrôler
l'accès aux opioïdes comme siro à la
codéine et dans la rue la demande est
toujours là le marché noir s'adapte un
peu comme le jeu du chat et de la souris
et ça les trafiquants ont très bien
compris
on
[Musique]